Russia
is a natural mediator and a natural partner.
I don't want anyone to regret
the conditions of the cold war
who has done so much harm
on the territory of the European continent.
Russia is as big as forty-six times France,
twice the area of the United States of America,
to one hundred and fifty million euros.
In the history of humanity,
never a country that did not have the population
to occupy its territory
has not been invaded,
has not been invaded the territory next door.
Explain that Russia will invade Ukraine,
it is a total lack of knowledge of the story,
of demographics
and the will of the Russian leaders.
Ukrainian is a
great country of forty-two million inhabitants
thirty percent of which is Russian at fault.
Ukrainian is a bridge,
a bridge between europe and russia.
The day you cut the bridge from one bank,
the country no longer makes sense.
Rather than pushing the kraine into one side or one
other,
very much better to push the kraine
have excellent relations with europe
and excellent relations with the Russians.
Because if you force the ukraine
to choose europe over russia,
what happens to the 30% of russian speakers in ukraine?
The 1st decision of the new Ukrainian government
having been to prohibit the use of Russian
on the territory
of ukraine,
this is a major mistake.